bueno los demócratas y los republicanos
acordaron una pausa de casi dos semanas
que les sirve a las dos partes a los
demócratas para tratar de apurar los
nombramientos oficiales de los jefes de
las carteras de las secretarías de la
nueva administración bailén que tienen
que estar confirmados en el senado y
también tratar de conseguir algún voto o
más votos si los hubiera ya de senadores
republicanos a favor del juicio político
al expresidente trump y los republicanos
acordaron esto porque necesitan
organizar su defensa del presidente tram
o isabella para los latinoamericanos que
no estamos muy relacionados con los
sistemas de juicio político tal y como
lo estipula la ley en estados unidos
porque donald trump si ya es
expresidente de eeuu va a ir a juicio en
el senado y no en una cámara como un
ciudadano normal
bueno el crimen o el crimen que es el
que se le acusa es un crimen de
incitación a la violencia son un delito
grave político y hay antecedentes hace
ya mucho tiempo pero hay antecedentes de
juicio político a funcionarios que ya no
ocupaban su cargo